Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast it.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm checking in on you this cause I care.
Okay.
In this time when everybody else is just thinking about themselves and their
issues,
I'm the person that cares about everybody else and now I'm going to tell you
about it because that's what the world is about.
Now,
the world is not about trying to go out and go.
You don't do a good thing unless everybody knows you did a good thing.
Here's me helping an old lady across the street.
Hang on,
granny.
Look into the look under my phone while I take a selfie of what a good fucking
person I am.
MMM.
And then I,
then I hashtag it humble.
Um,
just had the most amazing experience helping an old person across the street,
which I documented on my smartphone.
Hashtag humbled hashtag learn from your elders.
Oh,
I am in an extra county mood today.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It has nothing to do with the hipsters.
It's got nothing to do with the Manchurian candidate.
Hey,
by the way.
Okay.
You know,
I want to apologize to everybody in England,
the UK,
the,
what else do you call it?
The fucking,
uh,
there's something empire.
Great Britain.
Right.
Okay.
Specifically or pacifically depending on your education.
I would like to apologize to the football fence of the premier league.
I've been making fun of it saying it's fucking stupid.
They,
you know,
and,
and yeah,
Man City,
they had played a bunch of shit bump teams and they're just going to keep
wedding and this is going to be like no excitement whatsoever.
And just when you thought this pasty freckled Yank was right,
what happened?
Man?
City loses okay to the powerhouse that is Tottenham.
Oh,
no way.
Tottenham,
I could've told you fucking three years ago they were going to lose it.
That game,
nothing sends shivers down the fucking spine of football.
Feds as they shove fucking newspaper wrapped fish into their faces.
Okay.
Like the phrase we have taught in him next,
it's amazing.
Okay.
They fucking lost.
So I don't know what's going on.
So now,
you know,
I think Liverpool could actually tie
that.
That would be amazing.
Right after all of this running around and grabbing your legs and screaming in
agony,
the end of the year,
you got two champions
putting a whole fucking meaning to,
we are the champions.
We are the champions of the Premiere League,
Booboo,
booboo.
Uh,
no one is fucking better except for that other team do,
do,
do.
We are the champions and so is the other city.
I for the life of me don't understand how you have a fucking league that the
entire world is watching and you don't,
you're not,
you're not going to have these two teams play each other.
We are the champions of the world.
Yeah.
But so was man city.
We tied as champions.
Yeah.
So then what's going to happen,
you guys are both going to walk around in your cities,
which are championship hats for 2019.
Okay.
And then you'll run into each other on the fucking tube or the train or wherever
the fuck you are.
And then it's,
it's like literally like one of those stupid fucking feel good stories on
Facebook.
So and so had a twin that he was unaware of.
He's now 63 and he went to a mall on Long Island and ran into this fucking jerk
off.
That was his brother that he didn't know.
Right.
I always think that's hilarious when siblings meet each other in their sixties
that they didn't know existed.
And now what are you gonna talk about?
You know,
I had my gallbladder removed too.
You really are my brother.
You want to go play fucking catch.
Okay.
Um,
I don't have shoulders that work anymore.
You also dodged the draft.
Oh my God.
How could you not be related?
So that's what's going on right now.
And I,
I tried looking up to figure out,
you know,
the standings and all of that shit in the premier league.
Every wine will be chair this year.
Alright.
Standings
the same way.
It can end in a zero zero tie.
You can have two champions do two to two.
All right.
So right now Liverpool has two more points,
but I've learned that that doesn't mean shit.
Wish.
You know,
like how many games are left
and I gotta be honest.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't,
okay.
I'm still rooting for Liverpool.
I'm still paying attention.
But if the end of all of this fucking shit,
these fucking two assholes aren't going to play each other and Man City could,
could,
I dunno,
could not win it because they lost that Todd or ham.
Right?
Can I get bit Pip Tata Ham on his sandwich please?
Um,
I dunno.
Whatever.
You know what I'm doing?
I'm doing,
what I fucking hate people do when they come to this country is they just come
here and they tell me how fucked up it is.
Like I as an American don't realize it.
It's like,
dude,
I fucking live here.
Can you stop country splaining to me while you man spread across to me.
You
for male Caucasian.
Whenever the fuck these fucking broads a bitching about this week.
MMM.
Anyways,
there's a big strike that's supposed to be happening out here.
I'm hoping they're going to win the writer's guild.
You know what these fucking piece of shit agents did.
They actually fucking started packaging deals with them making more money than
the fucking person they were allegedly working for.
It's just classic them.
And you know what they do?
They go to bed,
they fucking sleep fine.
You know?
You know what's funny is none of my agents have brought this up.
Like,
yeah,
I mean I wasn't a part of it and it's despicable.
MMM.
Hey Nia,
we were just saying,
I haven't been on the podcast and forever.
I know.
Oh Wow.
You,
you,
you could not sound less.
Uh,
I dunno.
Missing of the podcast.
What's going on with your gorgeous,
you look in great.
Thank you.
Huh?
I know Nia woke up,
I woke up this morning and the first thing he says,
it was just like,
oh my God,
I was asleep until midnight and then I couldn't go to sleep until 4:00 AM.
And you know,
and you want as a husband to be like,
well that sucks for you,
but you know what that means.
You got to go get the little regret I did.
I made a wafs.
I came in there this morning.
She goes,
I go,
hey buddy.
She goes,
I want waffles.
Now the first thing right out of the gate,
she came in with a breakfast daughter.
I want waffles.
All right,
but I'm a strict dead so you know what I did?
I went right downstairs and I made her waffles.
That's right.
Yeah.
You're eating a healthy breakfast.
What'd you say,
sweetheart?
You want waffles?
Okay.
Absolutely.
Anything for you.
But then I didn't make waffles for Junia.
I did not because you've been crushing it on your diet and there's all kinds of
sugar and shit and that you don't need it.
And I didn't want to be the guy that handed your the crack pipe.
Nia,
this off Mike thing that you're doing on the podcast is about as exciting as
watching Liverpool and man city not play each other for the championship.
Everyone is champion in soccer.
If you fall down,
we'll fucking stop the game for 20 minutes,
Booboo,
booboo.
Um,
the more you watch soccer though,
you're more,
you can see how much it hurts.
You know,
when they get the spikes going.
Like a most solid was on that breakaway and that guy just basically peeled the
skin off the back of his calf.
But I love that he was on a breakaway and he kept going.
Most Sala actually looks like he's like,
looks like the Judd Apatow of premiere league soccer.
Nothing.
You just gonna walk out.
No,
I was just wanting to be like,
what they look,
they look like each other.
He's the best player in the s in into soccer league.
Yes.
Um,
Nia always looking out for me.
Always looking out for me.
Did you just say something about Tara Reid?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
Stanley Cup playoffs started now for all you English people over there.
You fight,
right?
What's that?
Is that like everybody sort of just mills around playing each other and then the
end,
the,
you know,
like whoever has the most points wins right now.
Everybody.
England,
it's just like,
that's a fucking terrible that
I'm going to compound it with a bad accent,
right way.
He'll fall.
Could talk like that mate.
Um,
yeah.
Started last night.
The islanders big win in overtime over your Pittsburgh Penguins.
Yeah.
Oh,
t loss.
Ot loss.
Uh,
San Jose Sharks.
I fell asleep.
I think they were handling in the nights it pretty well.
It's four to one.
Um,
and I didn't see what happened with Nashville.
No,
wait.
Yeah,
that was the,
yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
I watched,
I got a kid now.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
Um,
but I'll tell you what,
as much as I have a child,
as much as I'm a dedicated father,
I still had time to go out to my little fucking garage with my wonderful,
beautiful Gretsch broadcast to set.
And I was there,
I was working on that,
uh,
that Soundgarden song,
never the machine again.
MMM.
Which is a nine.
If I saw a site,
I figured out that it was in nine and then I figured out the main groove and
then that second groove where he goes on the toms,
I can never fucking here where he's at.
So I had to watch some kid on Youtube,
play it.
Um,
but I was,
I'm able to the whole song though.
What I love about the whole songs,
it's,
it's in nine and then it feels like it's switches but it never does.
He's just fucking with the time,
it was almost like he was either playing double time at first and then regular
time or he was playing regular time and then half time,
which I think is what he's doing and just the way he comes up with the drum
parts.
Matt Cameron,
the overrated underrated for this week.
Matt Cameron Drummer for Soundgarden Pearl Jam and a,
whoever's next band is going to be whoever they are going to be.
Um
Okay.
I Dunno,
I always thought he was like wasted and Pearl Jam that he could play all these
different time signatures.
As far as I know pro jam just plays in for you know,
so it's like you got like some fucking amazing like I dunno wide receiver and
you just have them on special teams.
Is that what it is?
Bill?
You Non Musician Khan?
Who the fuck are you to tell one of the biggest bands ever that they're wasting?
One of the great drummers of all time,
and I got a lot of fucking balls first.
First he attacked the Premiere League and now you're giving shit to fucking
whoever puts together Pearl Jam,
um,
with they fishermen.
Is that,
are they came up with Pearl jam?
You know what a pearls come out and visit oysters.
I can never remember.
Okay.
It is pretty amazing that we somehow found those fucking things.
Crustaceans buried in the fucking sand in the goddamn ocean.
And our stupid nosy ass is,
we're like the broad set of species.
You know,
you fucking wife just sticks.
They're fucking nose and everything.
Everything is curious to them.
They say they're curious.
It's like,
no,
you're nosy.
You snooping around fucking nuts.
All right.
Uh,
where do pearls come from?
[inaudible]
that's where it is,
right?
Why is my internet this fucking slow?
Have they just decided that I have to buy a new fucking,
although clams and Mussels can also produce pearls,
they do.
So they don't do so very often.
Everything has to be inclusive.
We're not saying,
we're not saying in clams and muscles aren't as good as the oysters.
Um,
okay.
As the oysters grow and internal organ called the mantle use is minerals from
the oysters food,
right?
Produce a substance called na who gives a shit.
Somebody sat and figured that out.
Somebody opened that up and found it and was like,
you know what?
I'm going to give this to the fucking woman in the tribe.
I want to bang and it was shiny and the other women didn't have it and she liked
him and the dude got his fucking prehistoric dick sucked and the trajectory of
that,
those butterfly wings flapping turned into I'll bull shit you see on TV with
Tiffany's.
You know
as a man,
if you ever produce one of those,
when are you going to get out of the ring?
Commercials like you really dish something should happen to you.
You should lose something.
I'm not saying physically,
but you should depth.
Somebody should take your flat screen away for like six months.
No sports packages.
Right?
But then again,
what kind of man who is into sports?
Well,
a lot of them because they're all about the fucking money.
These fucking Goddamn agents out here.
What a bunch of cons I do.
You know,
it's not that you steal,
it's that you'd go to bed at night with a smile on your face.
They get,
that's what kills me about the fucking agencies out here.
They don't even have any guilt of what the fuck they do.
Just like every other fucking corporations.
It's,
it's just fucking unbelievable.
Unfucking believable and they know they got everybody by the fucking balls.
February is going to fire their fucking age.
They know.
They know they did it.
You did it.
Congratulations.
Go get your fucking infinity pool.
You're fucking greedy.
Cons,
okay,
that out.
I'll tell you that's not just as business out to anytime you come up with an
idea,
all right,
and you get in business with somebody else.
You think that they are working with you.
I swear to God,
but at the end of the day,
you're going to end up fucking working for them.
Every time you think you're not the whore walking the block and you think you
finally got in the car and now you're the pimp,
you're not.
You're fucking walk in the block for somebody.
It's fucking ridiculous.
May they all die of fucking a fucking heart attack today when they go out and
eat their fucking surf and turf lunches,
gree cons.
Um,
yeah.
What am,
I can only get so fucking mad about it.
But what do you expect?
What do you expect?
You know,
that's,
that's what they do.
It's what they do.
That's what they do.
Yeah.
They're all about
the fucking money.
Um,
maybe that's what artists can do to fight back because we're not organized
enough.
Maybe we should just fucking,
you know,
and they still would kids,
not that you could say to him,
Hey,
what's up?
Do you agree?
He couldn't.
They'd be like,
hey,
how are you
just riding my Maybeck.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
moving on.
So the Bruins play the Toronto Maple leafs,
uh,
once again,
this,
and you've got to think at some point Toronto has to push through.
Will this be the year?
Um,
I am rooting for those guys,
but not this series.
Um,
and if they beat my Bruins than I will,
I will root for them because it's getting ridiculous.
You know what is amazing though,
and it really just goes to show you how nice people are in Canada on the
surface,
even though it's probably arguably more racist up there than it is down here.
And I know that that's a big statement,
but somebody has to offset Michael.
What's his face there?
Is it Michael Moore?
And remember his fucking ridiculous cartoon version of what Canada was like.
Everybody leaves their doors unlocked in their [inaudible] is gingerbread houses
up there.
Geez,
I,
I understand that.
He's too fat to actually go and do some fucking research,
which is why all this documentary.
So just op Ed pieces.
But that,
that whole didn't that fucking moron.
He should go fucking interview one guy of color who tried to make it in the Nhl
and just have him tell some fucking stories of playing minor league hockey up
there and what people said fucking last week too.
I'm on the ice.
Um,
anyway.
Oh Jesus.
Going after England now,
going after Canada,
talking about fucking broads bitching and US bill.
What's less?
Let's left El Salvador.
The look if you fucking people going to be down there.
So we're in a close together.
God it you do it right.
Um,
all right.
Okay,
here is another question I have.
No.
So here's the thing.
This just goes to show how nice they are.
Surface on the surface level of um,
and Canada is,
I remember when the Rangers have won it since 1940 everyone used in the 80s,
everyone was chanting 19,
1940.
So they were 40 something years in nobody chance 1967 maybe cause it's 67.
It's just too long.
1940 doesn't have a good rhythm here.
1967.
That's like when when the red sox finally won and Yankee fans couldn't chair
1918 anymore.
So then now they just go boss,
they went and they used to be 1918 and now they go,
Boston sucks.
They turn a one syllable word to a two syllable word cause they're too fucking
dumb.
You can't think of a fucking insult with two syllables.
I don't know.
Maybe I,
I,
I don't know.
I want understand,
but why isn't anybody,
it was always fucking shit.
And now our year,
nobody chanted 1906 and 1907 at the cubs,
but everybody chanted 1918 I got,
I gotta tip my cap to Yankee fence.
We're actually ESPN the way they fucking overhyped all of that,
and of course them,
they didn't get to the real,
you know the real story about it,
you know what I mean?
Where it was just like,
yeah,
we were just say horribly inept franchise and the Yankees were not good owners.
They didn't know what the fuck they were doing.
Right.
They didn't do that and that the Yankees were just this amazing organization
that picked Michael Jordan for decades in a row,
bottom one time,
and
no one's ever going to fucking do that again.
All right.
You got the Green Bay packers.
The Greenbay packers are on their way.
They went from Brett Fan.
All right.
To Aaron Rodgers now an errands done.
Okay.
I ask you this.
When Aaron Rodgers has done,
if they have another hall of fame quarterback that wins one or two bowls three
times in a row,
I don't think anybody's ever done that,
right?
I don't think so.
No,
they haven't.
Nobody's ever fucking done that.
MMM.
What is amazing too is they have three.
They do.
They have the greatest quarterbacks of all time.
Collectively,
Bart Starr,
Brett Farve,
Aaron Rodgers who can do better than that.
Terry Bradshaw.
Ben Roethlisberger.
Then you got nothing.
We got Tom Brady in my heart also says Steve Drogan drew Bledsoe.
But you know the stat people won't allow that.
Um,
blob greasy Dan Marino to have three.
Three is hard.
Let's see here.
Roger Starbuck.
Nope.
Nobody else there.
Wait a fucking minute.
God knows a bears and fucking brown so you don't have to think about them.
Alliance Bobby Lane.
That's it.
Huh?
Come on in buddy.
Yeah.
Hey.
Did you like the waffles?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
What are you doing today?
Come on up on the bed.
It's okay.
Come on.
You want to hold that?
All right.
Um,
well I'm talking about is anybody other than the packers have three hall of fame
quarterbacks.
Hello?
Huh?
Hell,
you want to say hello?
Say Hello.
Hello?
Say hello everybody.
Now she's getting shy.
Um,
yeah,
I got to give it.
I got to give it up to the Green Bay packers and which makes sense because
they've won the most NFL titles and super bowls.
But you guys,
you guys have heard this argument enough times.
Um,
it's time for me to read some advertising.
I only got one this week.
Oh,
hey buddy,
it's dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club.
Can she not be looking at this thing?
I'm trying to avoid the screen time.
She's looking at her herself,
not in her bed.
Say Bye bye.
Bye Bye.
Yeah,
it's all done.
All done.
I know you want it,
but you can't.
You can't.
You can't have it.
The whoa,
whoa.
What is she doing today?
No ma'am,
you going to music class
now?
She said remote
Fi.
Yeah,
she's not happy.
All right.
She's saying I want remote.
I want remote.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you never have to go to the Stila.
That's because they deliver everything you need right to your door and they keep
you fully stocked on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready in matter what you
getting ready for.
Have you covered head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it,
they have it.
You know what's hilarious?
Somebody is going to commit a murder one day and then just use all the dollar
shave club products and you know what if they actually get away with it,
the is is awful is that is it will be great for this company.
Not saying you need to be that clean.
Not saying we advocate murdering somebody and getting away with it.
We're just saying that's how you will be clean enough to get away with a murder
if this wrong.
That dollar shave club has doubled down and embraced.
Um,
and you have this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on
the products you use.
You determine what you want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at you Dilla from once a month to once every six months
plus what they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
Um,
and right now dollar shave club has a bunch of status sets you can get for just
five bucks,
like their oral care kit.
After that,
the restock box ships regular size
products@regularpricegetsyoustartasetforjustfivedollarsrightnowatdollarshaveclub.com
slash bar.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
You know what those sons of bitches did?
They actually gave me a little old gym bag,
green and white,
like the money they're making,
right?
It has my initials on it.
It's great old school guys.
Shit.
And I opened it up and there was a bunch of ping pong balls in there.
I think that's,
I dunno.
So you'd stuff doesn't smell.
I have no idea.
But I was looking for my favorite product that they have is the one wipe
Charlies.
You know what I mean?
That's like the poor man's,
but hey,
it's like toilet paper,
2.0 so you know,
you don't fucking leave let with a ticker tape parade still on your fucking ass
hole.
I'm sorry people,
I didn't,
I didn't mean to be there.
So if Mr or Mrs Shave Club is listening,
why don't you help both freckled stock up.
Maybe I could get a fucking membership and stop being such a fucking cheap
pastored here.
Um,
boom.
[inaudible] boom,
boom,
boom to do one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine by guy digging,
digging,
digging and gang.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
Paul Versey,
I love Paul Versey and you know something,
he had one of the most inadvertently hilarious tweets last night,
which I am going to give him shit about,
uh,
Paul versus on the road right now.
And I'm so proud of this guy.
He's,
he's doing his first like serious,
like headlining tour across the country.
Right?
And you know,
if you got somebody opening for you,
okay.
And you're like,
okay,
bringing them around the country and you're not a fucking asshole.
You want to see that person grow into a headliner,
which sucks for you because eventually you won't work together as much.
But you know,
you're not going to sit there and root against,
you know,
I'm sorry this isn't coming off as sincere as I wanted to to cause the muscle
clicking on his fucking website,
loading tour dates.
All right,
so this is where he's going to be.
He's got the punchline in Philly.
April 11th,
12th the 13th he's at Raleigh Improv on the 18th,
the 19th
and uh,
and the 20th all you people down south don't sleep on him just because he's
fucking a New Yorker.
Then he's at the New York Comedy Club on the 26th and the 27th of April.
All right.
Uh,
I got to tell you,
I saw him at,
um,
Gotham comedy club and he was stretching because they're waiting for Seinfeld to
get there.
And I just watched,
I watched him and it was just,
I was like,
there it is.
That man is ready.
He is now officially a headliner.
And all you got.
It's just people have to discover that.
So he's learning.
Uh,
it's Kinda cool to actually talk to him cause I remember being where he's at,
where he's like,
you know,
certain areas,
they know who he is and he does great.
And then you go down south and nobody knows who you are.
Same way for the southern comic comes up north.
It's like you went to a different country at first till everybody starts to know
who you are.
Imagine Ron White probably had that issue at some point during his career before
he became the superstar that he is,
um,
catch Paul Versey now.
And you can say,
I saw him when I saw him when,
uh,
but anyways,
he had this hilarious tweet.
He's always talking shit.
He goes,
I haven't smoked a cigar for 17 days,
which I'm very proud of him.
And then he,
then he writes,
tell me I can't do 30,
which is fucking hilarious.
Not only because there's people out there trying to get off fentanyl and there's
people evidently getting sold into slavery and Libya and all he's trying to do
is not smoke a fucking cigar and a Jacuzzi for a month
that stay strong fall.
But what I love is he goes,
tell me,
I can't do 30.
Almost like he was trolling people on the Internet and everything that I saw for
the most part was negative.
People were sending him pictures of cigars or they just write gay.
It just,
I don't know,
it's just like,
it's like you walked into a boxing ring with your Chin Out,
go on a date and punched me in the fucking Chin there.
Just me.
And the Internet is just mean.
You don't go to the Internet for support.
MMM.
But he hasn't smoked a cigar in 17 days.
And evidently he now thinks I know him in his head.
He thinks he's doing,
he's like what Reggie Miller used to do to the Knicks.
Like he's just burying three stealing the inbound pass,
running past the three,
the other side of the three point line and hit another one.
Um,
but I am proud of him too,
cause that's what,
you know,
I'll be honest with you to all the cigars.
Paul is not smoking.
I am smoking,
so I got to kind of lay off.
Um,
but I'm just not feeling like I want to,
cause that's like my only vice I really have right now.
Oh,
freckles is coming up on 140 days and no fucking booze.
Um,
20 goddamn weeks.
And I gotta be honest,
as much as I bring it up to you guys,
I always bring it up to you guys.
I know you're sick of it.
I just bring it up to you cause I want,
I want to,
I want to be held accountable.
No,
I seriously,
I just want this,
I want to keep going with this thing.
So I said I'm doing a fucking calendar year,
January 1st to December 31st and I'm actually thinking of going to my birthday
next year.
MMM.
I don't know.
I get weird with this shit.
Like now it's like,
all right.
You know,
I don't want to like,
I don't to end the streak,
you know,
tell me.
I can't fucking make it to 140 days people.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
I think that's going to be the podcast here for this week.
Congratulations to all the football fans in Europe of the premier league.
You must be going absolutely crazy right now knowing that there is an incredible
chance that uh,
there could be two champions this year or maybe there isn't.
I'm trying to look at my f is for family script that I have to read here in an
hour to table read.
I'm just going to get there early I think,
cause I can,
can't read this.
She yet,
it won't open for me.
Um,
anyways,
episode nine everybody this time next week we're going to be reading episode 10
and then sees a number four has been written and we still have to do all the
punch ups and the editing and all that.
That takes another fucking nine months.
But you know,
the big stuff,
the big heavy lifting is out of the way.
All right,
well that's it,
the podcast.
All right is done,
but there's going to be a little musical interlude here.
Um,
and then we're going to play your greatest hits.
Another half hour bonus of a greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from earlier this year.
10 years ago,
I don't know when I started doing sticks.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
Your cuts.
And we gone.
Paul Versey
of course was saying Babe Ruth was the greatest baseball player of all time.
Yeah.
And then he said all the usual shit.
He basically repeated shifted.
He heard on TV that he played at the dead ball era.
Right.
And a la head was also trying to tell me,
you know,
yeah.
He,
and I was just saying,
listen,
I'm not saying he's not one of the great players of all time,
but he's not the greatest of all fucking time for the simple fact.
He didn't play against the greatest.
All right?
He played in a segregated league with the Pedro Martinez,
the Mariano Rivera's.
Okay.
The Josh Gibson,
they weren't allowed in the fucking league.
Okay.
You didn't have to compete against Reggie Jackson.
He'd have to compete against these guys.
They weren't allowed in the league he was playing and basically a softball
league.
Okay.
With the top third.
What I would say would make,
you know would make the major league baseball nowadays.
Okay.
But I get it.
You gotta think like two thirds of them won't even fucking been there.
Then they tried to do that shit.
What bill?
It was only 10 teams.
There's dirty teeth now.
Yeah,
there was all solely fucking
2 billion people on the planet.
Now there's 7 billion.
All right.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll knock off like I'll get my next to 10% on his fucking numbers then
like give me a fucking break.
All you gotta do,
do he played baseball when people died of tuberculosis.
He played baseball.
Like there was a hit song,
but at the time
and that song was written in the 1890s and everybody thought it was too fucking
crazy.
What?
What is this devil music?
God dammit.
She,
what happens when you let them off the plantation?
They get a piano.
They couldn't even handle it.
Bat up a pap at that yet.
Add,
add,
add.
Abu [inaudible],
he played baseball.
That was a hit.
Baba Du,
Du,
Du de,
De,
de Boop,
boop,
boop.
You know,
and people would just hear it and then sit around wondering when they were ever
going to hear it again because they had no device to play it on.
Yeah,
that idea and Labu Babu,
Babu,
right.
That guy came to town and everybody stood around him and I played,
you played a fucking piano.
You see how they worked out back then?
Head,
shoulders,
knees and toes.
Knees and toes.
Head,
shoulders,
knees and toes.
Knees and toes.
And only white guys.
No blacks.
I Puerto Ricans,
head,
shoulders,
knees and toes.
Knees and toes.
Okay.
No big dump fucking gloves.
That looked like little people hands.
Give me a fucking break.
Not to mention Babe Ruth.
I mean they built a stadium towards his strength.
That right field fence.
Okay,
you could,
you could make a cop show with two toddlers and they could do the classic scene
where the fucking cop chases the perp down the alley and he gets to the chain
link fence and fucking jumps over it.
You could,
you could fill net with two toddlers with the right field fence in Yankee
stadium.
The House that Ruth built.
Alright,
you backed up to catch a fly ball.
It hits you like mid thigh and you fell into some guy's lap,
right?
So anyway,
give me a fucking break.
All right.
From 1930 on,
I'll give it to you.
All right?
But if you played in the teens,
he played in the arts,
he played in the 18 hundreds and even into the 20s.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right.
And I feel like every look,
every like um,
major sport has their three stooges era where one team won a bunch of fucking
championships.
All right.
I love the Boston Celtics,
but give me a break.
You look at them in the 1960s.
I mean,
it looks like it looks like a game being played at the y.
You know,
some Christian rec league.
All right.
The fucking Canadians want a bunch of Stanley cups when you know you had first
dibs on any guy within a 300 mile fucking radius and a 16 league.
They had first dibs on anybody in French speaking Quebec.
And we had,
you know,
we had first pick had like the best guy from Vermont.
Gee,
did you go on a run?
It's fucking ridiculous.
Okay.
And then the Green Bay packers who were actually the fucking Yankees of
football,
you know,
they,
they were,
when entitles,
when the Canton bulldogs,
we're still in the fucking league or I can't wait to give me,
come on.
All right.
Yeah.
Football was like a,
generally,
I think they played with a pumpkin back then.
I mean,
give me a fucking break.
All those chin,
a little star,
the house during the blah,
blah.
The only ones that I will let,
I will,
I will recognize their championships without a grain of salt.
I would say,
uh,
any of the New York Yankees from like the 1930 [inaudible] for the simple fact,
they went Babe Ruth Lou Gehrig,
Joe Dimaggio,
Mickey Mantle.
That's just,
nobody's,
nobody's ever going to do that again.
You're not going to get the Jordan of your error four times in a fucking roll.
All right?
You're just not going to do it.
So without a doubt,
I respect all of that type of shit.
But you know,
at the inceptions of these fucking leaks when crazy legs,
Johnson runs around googly eyes fucking Ulysses and give me a fucking break.
Okay.
He played in the deadbolt every,
you don't understand this guy had more devils
who was on the mound?
My great grandfather
got out of the both pan.
Oh freckles.
Was that the song they played when he came in said or enter Sandman?
They weren't facing cut fast balls back then.
I'm sure there was guys throwing 90 a hundred miles a fucking hour,
but just the,
the amount of bombs that were in that fucking league back then,
I don't want,
I didn't want to hear it.
Okay.
There was,
there's a,
there's a guy in the hall of fame for Good Luck in baseball.
He kept a section of rope that was used in an actual lynching.
Okay.
This is how long ago these fucking people played.
And you're going to sit there and act like in the inception of these fucking
leagues.
You know,
I,
I'm,
I'm looking at obviously in every era there,
there was a Jordan.
All right.
But just like the techniques and everything,
some of the records that were set back then,
they didn't have a fucking heavyweight fight.
It would go on for like a day.
Yeah.
They'd have like a fucking,
you know,
a 90 round fight.
Okay.
Now listen,
you're getting punched in the fucking head.
Well,
what kind of technique are you using?
Phil?
Did bare knuckle fucking the people pop.
Oh God,
go fuck.
I want to hear it.
I don't want to hear it.
All right.
The competition now is so much more insane that I,
I just think it would immediately.
Okay.
But I guess they would compete at the same level,
but like just the fact that it's now everybody gets to compete and not to
mention like,
I mean you could get fucking fathers out there.
I try and they try and teach their kid how to
throw a curve ball.
Yeah.
To get,
you know,
get the family out of the trailer park when the kids like six years old.
Okay.
Stunt the growth of,
of one of his fucking arms.
You know,
cause they live in a fucking trailer and somebody's got a growth on their face
that they want to have a gay they want to removed.
Okay.
Then all those kids go on out there that,
you know,
back in the day you went out and you played catch with your little kid.
Now you go out there and you from day one you try to teach him how to switch it.
Yeah.
It's insane.
All right,
so whatever,
I'm just saying,
so whatever you guys think,
Babe Ruth is the greatest baseball player.
Yeah.
It's so hard to say because all you can go by is this guy's fucking stats.
Who,
who,
who played back,
you know.
Okay.
I mean it was probably a guy better than fucking babe Ruth,
but he got polio.
You know what I mean?
I have it just,
all right,
I'm done.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burns the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 11th,
2011 2011 2011 whatever the fuck I got to say all this goddamn year.
Um,
how the hell are you?
Don't I sound bright eyed and bushy tailed?
I'll tell you why.
I'm going to tell you why right now.
Cause I tried to do the podcast last night.
I just can't do it on the days I travel,
you know,
flew across this country once again from Philly all the way out here.
And I'm like,
all right,
it took an early flight,
seven 30 in the fucking morning.
I'll land 10 30 La time somehow I'll take a little old man nap in the afternoon.
You know,
the old men take a nap.
You know what I mean?
We'll,
you'd lie in the fetal position with your hands in the prayer prayer pose
between your fucking milk white thighs.
If you're me sitting there and you're bbds and a tee shirt,
black dress socks on,
faced in towards the cushion.
That's an old man nap.
Yeah.
And then somewhere through what?
You roll over on your back.
Start breathing out your fucking mouth in and out.
Just,
you know,
that's what all people do when they old guys.
Do you need to do it right in the fucking living room so no one could watch TV.
Just dominate in the house.
Yo,
man balls just hanging out.
This you get tighty whities um,
that was the plan.
That's what I was going to do.
Then you always end up getting cold too.
I never understood that.
If I lie on the couch awake and I'm not moving,
I never get cold.
But the second you fall asleep,
you get you gotta util you don't Chile.
Why do you good Chili when he just leaving?
Um,
AH,
Jesus.
I hate myself.
This week I'm writing it.
It's,
I'm not even going to fucking get into this shit.
How fucking unfunny I was last night on the podcast.
I try to record this in for like 20 goddamn minutes.
I to the point I have to put up one of the outtakes at the end of this.
I've never done that.
I want to put up an outtake of me just quitting on a story.
Um,
I'll put that up at the end,
but before I,
before,
before I get into the rest of the podcast,
ladies and Joe,
but,
um,
I got a couple of things I have to hype.
Uh,
like tonight for all you people in Los Angeles,
I'm going to be doing a benefit for a,
all the victims of the earthquake slash tsunami,
um,
over there in Japan.
I'm going to be doing it at the Catalina jazz club tonight.
It's at six,
seven,
two,
five sunset boulevard,
just east of Highland.
All right,
I'm going to have the link and everything up on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
The show starts at 8:00 PM,
uh,
it's called cabaret cares songs for Japan.
So it's actually comedy and a,
and some music.
So there'd be some Broadway stars down there.
Uh,
daisy Egan's the one who actually put it together for those of you are in broad
way.
Uh,
she won a Tony Award when she was 11.
Alright.
Sang at Carnegie Hall and killed it at 11.
All right.
Got got the fucking award from a,
who's that?
That check there that I said that women should still be dressing like a
breakfast,
a breakfast at Tiffany's.
What the Hell is her name?
There are the one who looks like a little fucking a,
not a rat.
Not a hamster.
What's a cute little fucking big brown?
I'd wrote it.
Okay.
That's what she looks like to me.
She looks like,
Oh God.
I wish we could've gone on a date with her and said that to her.
You know,
red is she starting to like me and it just look across,
they're trying to say some pepe le Pew like Romantic Shit.
You know,
come here.
My little brown.
I'd wrote it.
Yeah.
Ah,
fuck you ever notice it.
I'll fucking racist at is pepe Le Pew.
I never noticed I talk about that on the podcast.
Well,
I don't care if I did got a wing an hour every week.
You're not going to fucking repeat yourself sitting in your Goddamn cubicle.
How many times you told that fucking joke?
The two guys,
we'll have you do a book.
You know,
just waiting for a new employee so you can hit them with the same old fucking
story.
How dare you?
How dare you question me?
You motherfucker and your Goddamn cubicle,
Huh?
What are you doing?
Uh,
you hate yourself right now because you ate the whole Cinnabon cause you lied to
yourself.
I'm going to cut it in half and I'm not going to do it.
And what happened?
You cut it in half and you saw that sugary goodness,
Huh?
Just fucking coming down and the fucking baker just that's on top.
Just dripping down the side.
And what do you,
you went down on it.
You went down on it like some horror just got off a bus in a strange city.
That's what you did.
Now you had your sugar rush,
you like,
yeah,
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to make it to the whole day.
Cinnabon.
The poor man's 12 hour energy.
Hey,
can somebody please explain to that commercial to me when those guys take that
five hour energy,
whatever the fuck it is,
they take it and the guy goes,
yeah,
all right,
I'm ready.
And then he sits down,
puts his feet up on the table,
reads a newspaper.
I thought it's supposed to make you go work.
What was the deal out?
God,
am I going to suck on this one toe?
You know what?
Fuck you guys every once in a while.
I have a bad set.
I think I'm going to bomb this week.
So anyways,
getting back to what I was talking about.
So I had planned on taking a nap and old man fucking nap by the way,
strip it right down in my underwears and sleeping on the couch like a fucking
the old man that I am.
But uh,
the masters,
the masters was on and I had to watch it because we're already McIntyre from
Ireland.
Looked like he was gonna win the damn thing,
you know?
Plus I'm always rooting for tiger,
you know,
because I have issues with women.
I have such issues with women that I actually think that at their women meetings
where they trash guys,
they actually have like a little counter on how many tournaments it's been since
tiger actually one.
And they're trying to sit there,
you know it's a fucking braid.
Their Harry muffs just sitting there.
It's a braid.
Their hair,
he must right.
And they're just sitting there going,
you know why?
You know why he hasn't won?
Because behind,
yeah,
we get,
Amie gave me any,
the strong woman.
I know this saying that Shit,
so I'm fucking ruining for tiger.
Even though I had a bet with Keith Robinson,
every year we bet the masters and every year he picks tiger and then I pick a
white guy,
you know,
it's sort of fun with racism and I send them Texas like white power and this is
a white man's game and you're not taking over this one.
We'll give you,
we'll give you a football,
we'll give you a basketball.
Y'All black people actually took over baseball there for a minute.
Then they just stopped giving a shit.
You know,
it was too boring.
I don't know what it was.
I liked that when they do those things on,
on,
on sports shows,
we have to get more African Americans.
End of the day of a baseball,
they don't like it.
You know
what the fuck?
Why are you going to force a fucking sport down or you know what it is is
because baseball sucks as they left.
Actually.
No,
the Latino saved it.
What am I a def jam comic.
What's with all the race shit this week bill?
Yeah,
but see a white person played baseball shit.
Fuck
God.
His Jersey.
I'll snug up on his nuts and shit.
Um,
do you guys see
what's his face?
Manny Ramirez tested positive again a and then he just steady fucking skedaddles
retired.
I'm going to go to stay with my dad.
I didn't like how papel bond was giving him shit.
I thought that was a country move.
I get it.
You're obviously didn't like the guy when he fucking play it on your team,
but you don't have to be a content.
Throw the guy under the bus saying all the shit that these guys are already
going to say.
It's kind of like this,
this ass hole here in the uh,
okay.
One of the,
one of those guys in the New York Post,
you know,
those guys,
they uh,
or is he,
where is he one of those guys on a round the horn that show that just makes
absolutely no sense.
I don't understand that show.
I don't understand how the points work.
I don't understand why that guy who sounds like somebody imitating somebody
stupid,
you know,
host this show is,
is always clicking.
Why he's in charge of the scoring.
I don't understand it.
I don't,
I don't get it.
And it's always like four guys talking at once at a,
I like Wally.
So that's his name.
I add,
I've got,
I don't get that fucking show.
I think this guy is one of those guys on that shelf.
So anyways,
if you,
if you watch the uh,
the masters,
which I've watched for the last three years,
I went to it last year,
two years ago I watched Kenny Perry.
I'm watching this guy just,
you know,
it looks like a regular guy.
I'm like,
oh great,
he's going to win the masters.
And then I watched just the fucking wheels come off the entire last day and the
guy completely chokes and I got to tell you something.
Golf is the worst game to choking.
You know,
if you're a goaltender in the NHL and you let up a bad goal.
I mean how long does that take?
You know what fucking a split second you let up another bad one.
People bull.
Yeah.
I mean what do you have a bad period?
They take you out of fucking gay.
It's maybe a half hour of your life and that's a long fucking time.
You missed the big shot.
You call a fucking time out like Chris Weber or whatever.
Right.
It's fucking over.
It's done.
You walk off the court.
That's it.
I guess he gets shit for it still bill Buckner ball rolls through his fucking
legs in the fan that match when it all right.
How long did that take?
Did you choke in golf?
I guess I'm talking about the game itself.
I'm not talking about the amount of shit that you get cause that's usually
lifelong.
Cause I heard that bill Buckner had to move to like Idaho with some shit.
But what I'm saying is going through the agony of the choke is anywhere from a
split second up to about,
I don't know,
2025 minutes.
But in golf it's hours,
hours and hours.
It's three hours watching this kid just all over the fucking course.
And he know what he's 21 years old.
I thought he handled it tremendously.
He handled it tremendously.
One point he kind of laughed and shook his head that one hole when he was
standing in between a couple of houses.
I've never seen houses on a golf course before my life.
That's how bad his shot was.
It ricocheted off a tree
is ball landed in like a kitty pool.
I'm telling you folks,
it was off the golf course.
Ah,
Jesus,
I sucked this week.
Um,
so this Douche fucking rights,
uh,
his shirt was stained in the front.
Everybody shirt was stained.
You're playing fucking golf in the sun.
Fucking fat.
Fuck you.
Goddamn shirt was probably staying when you typed this.
Listen to what this guy said.
It was staying in the front,
untucked in the back.
A little boy lost Rory mcilroy trudged up the final holes at Augusta national
and Sunday afternoon as if looking for somewhere to cry.
His swagger had shriveled up into was stoop is boyish.
Smile became nod lips.
Now I want to ask some.
Anybody else watch it to anybody.
See at any point where he was going to cry,
I thought he held his composure.
Granted he played fucking horrific.
He definitely maybe,
you know,
started to panic or whatever.
I'm not a golfer.
I don't know what the fuck happens,
but he didn't look like he was going to cry.
I hate these.
I hate these fucking sports writers.
You know what I mean?
You already have a word count,
so you gotta throw in another adjectives in there.
He's 21 fucking years old.
And then what happens is when something like this happens in sports,
then these fat fuck sport writers who sucked in gym class,
you know,
they did.
You know,
they were the kids who got like the bloody nose and playing dodge ball.
Then they just start turning up the fucking pressure.
You know?
That's what sucks about joking those cause now everyone's going to be sitting
there going like,
you know you'd had that collapse at the master's,
barely had time to reflect.
Even at the end I thought he'd said it.
Well he said,
what?
What's going to,
what do you,
what are you thinking about right now?
And he just said,
listen,
it's too early.
It's too early to reflect on what it just happened.
Talk to me in a couple of days.
I thought it was really fucking mature,
whatever.
So I support the guy.
I hope you fucking wins his God damn thing again.
But fuck,
I lost 50 bucks cause tiger ended up having a higher score than Rory.
I just picked the top white guy.
I started watching the second day.
So then I bet with Keith and now I owe that son of a bitch.
50 Bucks,
you know,
kills me is he's just going to blow it on another itchy sweater.
All right,
let's get into the podcast here for this week.
Uh,
where the hell am I here?
But the by hype to think,
Oh,
another thing I have to hype,
the other thing I have to hype this week is people have been asking me,
um,
I have a date at the punchline is San Francisco on Monday,
May 9th.
And people are asking me when the tickets go on sale.
They go on sale this Friday,
April 15th.
All right.
That's the deal.
Go to the wild.
The punchline,
San Francisco website,
which of course I don't have that fucking information,
but you could Google it,
right?
Anyways,
so let's talk about my weekend.
I had two awesome shows.
Okay.
Pet two awesome shows.
I did one at the records theater and Towson,
Maryland.
And uh,
then the next one I did was at the tower,
the tower theater in uh,
Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania.
Legendary venue I might add.
Okay.
And you know,
I'm all about the history.
David Bowie recorded a live album.
Their first time.
Bruce Springsteen got a check for five grand,
was standing on Braf who stood on that stage and performed,
uh,
average white band record,
their live album.
Uh,
the fuck is it called cut the cake,
pick up the pieces.
I can see your Pussy,
lips,
whatever the fuck it's called.
That all was all recorded there.
So I got to go down there and become part of that fucking history and uh,
it was awesome and I want to thank everybody who showed up both to the Maryland
Gig and to the one out in Philly.
Um,
Maryland Gig was amazing and then Philly just completely took it to a whole
nother level.
Um,
it was just an awesome,
awesome crowd.
And uh,
actually had some lady,
some lady came up to me at the end of the show and I had run out of DVDs.
I didn't bring enough and uh,
she was all bummed out.
She goes,
you know,
my son was supposed to come tonight,
but he's on house arrest.
Okay,
Saigon,
it's too bad.
I ran out of DVD.
She's like,
that's all he wanted.
He just wanted to meet you and get a DVD.
Sit Down my liberal side.
I'm starting to feel bad.
And I go,
all right,
well you know,
uh,
maybe you send me an email,
maybe I could send one out to them or whatever.
Right?
And she goes,
oh my God,
I would really appreciate that.
And I went,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
What did he do?
You know,
I don't want to send it out to some fucking pedophile.
I'm attempted racist.
Some guy who's a steel in music online,
I'm fucking with you.
So I guess it turned out some 18 year old kid punched his 11 year old brother.
So her son Fuck head that he is not kidding.
Her son,
18 years old went over and beat the shit out of the 18 year old because he'd
beat up his fucking 11 year old brother.
And because we live in such a pussy time,
because that kid basically got his ass kicked for doing what he did.
This kid ends up on house arrest.
Can you,
can you believe that kind of a fucking country.
Who Do we live in
where the 18 year old,
older brother of an 11 year old who got beat up by an 18 year old can't then go
over and kick the shit out of that 18 year old without sitting in his own
fucking house,
missing a comedy show.
You know?
So now I have to mail them a fucking DVD.
That's another goddamn branch off a tree in the rainforest.
And what,
what,
what did that fucking kid learned?
The other kid,
what did he learn that is,
because he's probably gonna have a lawsuit right there is profitable.
His way of earning income is to walk around and beat up 11 year olds who have
older brothers.
Okay.
Oh,
I tell you the hypocrisy.
Um,
so anyways,
I was sitting out there and uh,
I did this gig out there and uh,
upper Darby,
Philadelphia,
it doesn't that sound nice.
Upper Darby,
upper class,
upper,
we're up on a hill.
We're looking down on the poor people.
Um,
that's not what Philly is like in Upper Darby.
It was one of the most horrific neighborhoods I've ever driven through.
I'd never been like,
you know,
I don't mind driving through the projects during the day cause the people I see
out,
I'm like,
all right,
these are just fucking hard work and people coming off from their jobs.
It's when the sun goes down,
you know basically any way you're at when the sun goes down,
that's when the fucking assholes come out.
Okay.
Both in the inner city and out in the suburbs.
You get all this,
no serial killer walking around the suburbs out in the broad daylight.
He comes out at night.
This is one of the few neighborhoods during the fucking day
you,
I can't even explain it like I dunno,
go Google some pictures.
Upper Darby in Philly.
It's,
it's unbelievable that Americans have to fucking live this way.
Yeah.
Ashley will do.
My opening joke was after driving through that neighborhood,
I was like,
what the fuck is New Orleans Bitch and above?
You don't know what it looked like.
These these fucking houses,
they look like,
you know the end of all in the family when they go going down that horrific
street of houses and Queens,
that's what it looked like.
It looked like a,
except they were all rusted out and I swear to God I thought they had like tin
roofs or something.
So many ways.
As long as long story short,
I have a 7:30 AM flight the next fucking day.
Oh by the way,
the reason why I got lost going over there is because I was using my smartphone
and I'm using the little map thing and I swear to God,
that fucking thing.
I'm going back to maps.
The rand McNally,
you know what I liked about the rand McNally at no point when I was looking at
it,
did it shut off?
Did it go black?
The screen went black and then I had to scroll my thumb down it while I'm still
trying to continue to drive.
The whole fucking thing was horrific.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm completely,
I don't,
I'm going to go on a limb here and say we have enough technology.
What do you guys think?
Am I crazy?
I like that three D TV.
Let me ask you guys is,
are you really,
you guys really going to go out and buy those fucking things and then there's
going to be the tipping point where more people have them then don't have them.
So then eventually I'm not going to be able to see shit on my regular fucking
TV.
Three d TV is to be,
is it,
is it nuts?
Fucking clear enough with the HD TV?
Is it not clear enough that I can see the,
the fucking cartilage inside the nose of the fucking newscaster mean?
They kept saying that when I was watching the masters of Hilarious,
they go the masters and three lakes,
like I really need to be sitting there bending back.
Like I'm watching the matrix is the golf ball goes flying over my fucking head.
You know,
you're living from outside life is in three d Gulf for a fucking walk.
It's a total scam.
Think about how much you want it.
I want to tell you guys this,
right?
Just think about this shit.
Think about all the shit on three d.
All right.
Do you want to watch this DVD?
Need to watch two and a half men in three d like wow.
I feel like I'm sitting on the couch with them.
Okay.
Do you need to watch the news in three d?
I'm going to tell you right now,
sports in three d is going to suck.
Okay.
It's going to suck.
I'm gonna tell you right now it's,
it's,
it's gonna.
I already think what the Hd TV,
it's all,
it's,
it's getting to the point where it's so clear.
It's like HD is like clearer than real life.
Yeah,
I dunno.
It's like,
it's like a fucking acid trip.
I remember one time I was watching this baseball game with this other comedian.
Okay.
And we were sitting there watching the game when HD TV first came out,
we weren't even watching the game.
He was pointing at somebody and like the third row,
go and look at that guy shirt.
Look how fucking orange his shirt is.
And it was,
it was literally an orange that did not exist in real life.
Okay.
So what happened?
Everybody bought those fucking three d,
uh,
bought the flat screen TVs,
you know now old people with their little square TV from the greatest
generation.
They got to go out,
buy a flat screen TV that breaking their fucking hip as they try to put it up on
top of their old fashioned radio where they used to listen to FDI and his
fireside chats.
Yeah,
right.
They finally get the fucking thing up there.
Yeah.
The bankers took then their entire retirement and now you consequent to go out
and buy three d TVs.
Okay.
It's got to fall down on their fucking old heads and that's going to be yet
please people.
Please don't buy those three d TVs.
It's a fucking scam.
What's going to happen with your old flat screen TV?
What are you going to do with that?
Just going to throw it out.
It's going to end up in the ocean.
It's talking about this this weekend.
We are going to be able to walk to Europe on on old flat screen fucking TVs.
You don't need it is what I'm trying to tell you.
I've never,
I can't remember the last time I fucking prayed that a a that a technology was
going to bomb the way have with those,
those 3d fucking TVs.
All right.
And I don't want to hear any,
you fucking cunt sending me emails talking about the discovery channel and how
the fucking do from the Goddamn rain forest frog is going to drip off right
until you fucking lap.
And if you smoked some weed man,
how fucking cool that's going to be.
And then all the Frat Boys,
who would've,
well porno woo boy in three d.
What about fucking a real girl?
What about that?
You know,
all right,
I'm going to give you a porno.
I will give you porno cause you know what's going to be great.
I can't wait for that fucking sex suit to come out.
You know,
they're working on that like a full body sex suit is actually scientists working
on that,
having mature conversations,
uh,
you know,
like nuts snickering at all talking about these,
these fucking,
as they develop in like dissections and basically what it's going to be.
Do you remember that?
That little one.
See that Arthur Fonzie rally used to wear when he'd be in his garage working on
some fucking 1940s rusted out hunk of Shit.
Remember that the thing that he would wear,
it's kind,
kinda dirty version of like those jumpsuits that the caddies were at the
masters,
you know
course Brittany would wear one,
roll it up and have her titties hanging out of it and talk,
you know saying like,
oops,
did I just touch your Dick again?
Whatever the fuck she used to sing about.
Right.
Hey,
do you know in rolling stone they had the top one hardest 100 artists of all
time and Madonna was like 50 something and I was going to get upset,
but I was just like,
you know what,
how many pop stars can last fucking 30 years.
But then I thought there was justice because they had like other famous artists
writing like you know like quest love would write the one for prince you two
would write the one for like a,
you know,
fucking rolling stones or whatever.
But I thought it was really fitting that Britney Spears wrote the one from
Madonna,
although it should have been lady Gaga.
She's doing a fucking songs,
right?
Like fucking word for word.
She's doing a Mashup without what?
That Mcdonald's lyrics over the top is that what the fuck she's doing anyways,
let me get back to what the fuck I was talking about here.
Okay.
Which I can't even remember.
The fuck is wrong with my brain this week.
What the fuck was I just talking about?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You know,
so you know what?
I'm fucking Rory.
Whatever the fuck his name is,
right?
Mackle Roy right now.
Okay.
I had this whole fucking thing when it's the final days of the masters and I'm
just limping my way through 18 holes of this fucking podcast,
this podcast right now,
it's in between those two little,
just like Rory was on the fucking 13th or the 15th fucking Hole,
whatever the hell it was.
What happened to all fat tits,
a Phil Mickelson.
I wanted him to win another one.
I'll tell you,
it killed me that I wasn't there at the masters.
If you ever get a fucking chance,
you got to go.
I went last year,
I've been to a super bowl and it's never really bugged me that I didn't go to
another one.
It bugged me for the first couple of years,
but once the game was over and I still had two grand in my pocket and I didn't
have to go to uh,
an airport and stand in line and do that horse shit again and fly home and it's
never bugged me.
But this one seriously bugged me that I wasn't there.
He got to go once in your life.
You got to go down to Augusta,
but I've got to tell you,
it's one in one of the shittiest fucking,
uh,
it's not even in a shitty neighborhood.
It's just like,
you know,
you know when they show that,
when you drive up and you look at the Georgia Pines,
whatever the fuck they are,
when you drive up to the clubhouse,
first of all,
as a spectator,
you're not allowed to drive up there and you'd never see it.
You're not allowed to walk around that side of it.
That's just for the players and the members,
but right outside of that,
like a half a mile away.
He's like a fucking waffle house at Denny's at JC Penney's.
Just like just that shit.
Mcdonald's
ace hardware store,
the way they shoot that thing is they shoot the masters the same way they shoot
like Elvis's house.
Like when you look at Elvis's house,
it looks like it's just like it's in Savannah,
Georgia or something.
And then you go to Elvis's house and I swear to God there's like an,
I hop like right next door.
And I was like,
yeah,
that makes sense.
That's why he was so fat.
He could just walk down his driveway and go get some pigs and blankets and he'd
just go over there.
You know?
Was Elvis the first fat coke kid?
You know,
they talk about that.
Like most people do coke,
the,
they're not,
uh,
they fucking lose weight or some shit,
you know,
I dunno.
You know something,
he got fat too.
Before we really had all the preservatives in there.
He was just fat on some,
what the fuck was he eating?
Peanut butter and fucking banana fried sandwiches on his fucking jet.
Splitting his jumpsuits.
Oh,
another jumpsuit.
Bringing it back around again.
That's exactly what those,
those,
those caddies got those jumpsuits.
They all,
the missing is the cake.
And they could come down on one knee.
That's what they should do.
Come down on one knee holding out the Cape.
Is Somebody fucking Putz for the master's?
That would add some excitement,
wouldn't it?
All right,
let's get back to Philly.
So anyways,
so I got to,
I got to 7:30 AM flight.
All right.
So I'm thinking,
all right,
that means I gotta get up at fucking five 30 return the rental car and all that
horseshit.
Why don't I stay at a hotel right next to the airport?
So my travel agent gives me the whole list of,
uh,
of options of where I can stay.
So I'm like,
yeah,
fuck it.
All right.
I checked them out.
And one of them is the Sheridan Sheridan,
respected name,
a very quality hotel.
I say,
I'm going to stay there.
And the price reflected that it was a quality hotel costs me like,
oh,
you know,
180 bucks or something like that was a lot of fucking money.
So a one 99 something like that,
you know,
for Philly,
that's a lot of fucking money considering I was right outside upper Darby.
So anyways,
here's my travel tip for you.
Do not ever stay at the fucking Sheridan.
Yeah.
At the Philadelphia International Airport.
It is a beyond ghetto.
Sharon and I,
and it's so fucking ghetto that I,
I knew it was a fucked up Sharon before I even went into it.
I pulled up and it looked fine.
I got out of my car,
it looked fine.
And as I walked into the place,
as I was walking in,
these four chicks were coming out and they just look like horse from a reality
show.
Awful tattoos on their feet.
Tidies up and pushed together these cheap ass looking stripper shoes.
And I went out and though,
oh no,
not,
not a bad hotel.
Please God,
please.
I start praying to the travel gods,
please,
please don't let this be a bad hotel.
You know?
I'm like,
wait,
but you know,
at first I was like,
all right,
what?
What are these like call girls?
So they just get done servicing some fucking married business guy on the road.
Is that what they did?
But it was like 12 noon.
It's like,
no,
no.
Call Girls are up at 12 noon.
All right.
They already wiped fucking washed off.
The vaginas hosed up down at like eight in the morning and now they just fell
asleep face down in a fucking pile of glitter and then not to wake up against it
like five in the afternoon.
That's how it works.
And they wake up,
they fucking,
you know,
okay.
I Dunno what they do.
You know,
they put some fucking vitamin E on the,
on the ligature marks around the neck from the night before.
You don't,
you know what's fucked up about ligature?
Nobody ever uses that statement unless somebody's got choked to death.
You know,
ligature,
my,
no,
it does never any ligature marks because you know why?
Because these girls who are into that type of shit,
if they survive the encounter,
they fucking,
they were that little,
uh,
that little ass got the next day around their neck.
You know,
the hoary one,
a choker.
That's what they were to cover it up.
You have to have a girl wants you to do that once you a choker.
I remember one time I was with this girl,
right?
And she,
uh,
she will all this type of shit.
She wanted me to slap her in the face and all this,
all this crazy shit that,
uh,
that all these fucking women shows they never address.
They never addressed the amount of fucking women that like,
that.
They like it rough.
It's fucking and say,
unless I just keep picking the same kinds of fucking women,
but it's ridiculous.
The amount of fucking Bra that I've gone out,
you know,
fucking women's Lib,
fucking Blah,
blah,
blah.
My career comes first.
If we get married,
I'm not taking your last name,
Yadda Yadda,
fucking Yada.
Right?
Then you get them in,
you know,
the fucking all pro women.
There's pro women that,
and I'm making my own money and fucking,
you know,
in a couple of other fucking lyrics from some stupid Beyonce song,
right?
All that fucking horse shit,
you're going to respect me eyeball to eyeball the images of women on TV,
all that fucking horse shit.
And then you get them back to your place and lo and behold,
they have a rape fantasy,
you know,
am I the only guy by the only fucking guy.
So anyways,
so I was seeing this fucking broad,
right?
And she's going to fucking college,
she's getting her Mba and all that type of shit.
So this is the first girl she ever asked me.
She told me that she wanted,
uh,
me to choker.
I was like,
no,
I'm not doing that.
And she's like,
why not?
And I said,
well,
because I'm not fucking going to call the cops.
Like,
how am I going to talk my way out of that if you fucking pass out and I got my
fingerprints around you,
God damn neck and your naked body.
I mean,
that just sounds like one of those fucking things from,
even if you come around,
I'm going to have some sort of fucking assault charge and then you're going to
feel guilty because everybody's gonna know because the cops are there.
So then you just going to be like,
yeah,
I didn't want him to do it.
So you can somehow skip away with your fucking integrity.
I'm not doing it.
Of course I did.
Of course they did.
Eventually.
But there's a technique I can't actually,
you got you gotta be,
you gotta make sure you're up a little higher and underneath and you gotta you
gotta do it and then not be doing it.
Do it.
And then not doing it.
Don't just fucking grab it.
Like you don't grab that next like fucking David Tyree and the helmet catch.
You don't want to do that cause you got to,
you got to choke him out.
Uh,
you know,
unless you're really good at CPI,
I'd have fucked it.
Ended up talking about that shit.
That's it.
Really.
Yeah.
You know something.
I'm going to talk about that in my act.
Jesus said,
I'll bring the psychos out.
Um,
I'm going to talk about that.
My Act,
you just heard a fucking preview of a joke.
I really want to bring that up.
Okay.
The amount of fucking women,
they got that thing right.
They are all independent and that type of thing.
Then you get them in the bedroom.
So like you want it,
they want you to you to kick the shit out of him.
But they got that list that,
that fucking line.
They want to feel the man's power but still feel like safe overpower me.
But like do it in like a nice way,
but not nice but nice.
Do you know what I mean?
I know exactly what you mean.
You filthy fucking whore.
Uh,
all right.
I have to get up.
I gotta get off this subject.
This is just going to get too freaky to be talking about this by myself.
Uh,
this is the choke 'em out podcast everybody.
So anyways,
so I see these fucking,
just these,
these whores father didn't stick around,
you know,
George Foreman Grill.
Eaton fucking just,
just never had a chance for girls just coming out.
Just never had a fucking chance.
And you know,
just dressed like fucking truck stock,
fucking whores.
And the sad thing is,
is they think they look good and they don't even realize the vibe that they're
putting out.
They don't know any better.
They don't fucking know any better.
All right?
There was a rusted out car in their front yard that day.
They were born and they never had a fucking chance.
You know,
the only fucking male voice that was in their household when they was growing up
was the Billy Best that the Diff,
they're fucking dad left behind.
You know what I mean?
Just,
they just never had a fucking chance.
So that was my first red flag and I was gone off.
Maybe.
Maybe they use some sky miles.
Is that how they got in here?
And I just walked in the second I walked in,
I,
I just,
I could just tell the caliber of human being that was in there straight across
the board here.
Alright.
The caliber or white person,
the caliber of black person.
The caliber of fucking male,
female,
you just can tell.
You know what I mean?
I saw some black dude,
you know,
when they get their hair braided but they don't have enough money to fucking get
it braided enough so they got all those little hairs sticking out of it,
you know,
cause you can't see the scalp in between the braids,
it's not looking fucking right.
It's just not looking right.
The fucking white dude with the cheap Anderson little suit,
the fucking creased up Brown loafers with this gold lamay horse shit on the
front of it.
You know,
shoes look like they cost 11 bucks and I'm just going out and now,
Oh God,
least let the fucking room be clean,
you know?
So I check in the lady behind the counter,
she was nice enough,
you know,
I don't know how she ended up at this fucking Sheridan.
Maybe she has stepped out of line at the big a stockholders meeting.
This is,
this is their stairs.
Sheridan,
Siberia.
So then I go up to my room and uh,
it's weird.
It had like one of the,
almost looked like a little house.
She come walking in,
there's a door and right next to it there's this big window for some stupid
fucking reason.
If I want to overlook half the elevators in the fucking poor excuse for a pool
that they had,
so the blinds were down.
All right.
So I open it up and it's a sweet,
I'm like Nice.
It was a nice room.
It wasn't bad at all.
So I'm in there for like five fucking minutes and I hear this knock on the door,
right?
Guy fucking knocks on the door.
It was covered in foam,
so that's what it sounded like.
And I opened the door and there's a guy standing there with this giant coffee
table and he goes and he's trying to walk in with this giant cocktail.
I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I go,
you got the wrong room.
I didn't order a table.
He goes,
not all this,
this tables is your room's missing a table,
Mike.
It is.
They go,
yeah.
Yeah.
The last people who were here broke the other table.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
What'd they have?
Like a party or something.
Anyway.
Yeah.
I thought he was going to say no.
He went like,
yeah.
And I go,
well did they fucking fumigate the place now?
I think everything's been just dawn.
I'm,
you know,
I'm laying in fucking angel dust and cocaine and Shit,
you know?
Okay.
It keeps getting worse that I'm sitting there for another couple of minutes and
then I just hear this lady telling the story,
right?
Yeah.
Tell me that mother fucker can't come up
with a motherfucker baby.
And I'm like,
is that it leads?
Is it at at least a guest?
Okay.
Is that at least a guest?
And I fucking open the blinds to my window and she's one of the people cleaning
the rumps just cursing up a fucking store loud as fucking hell.
Like all broke.
He broke people are the loudest fucking people because they live near the
freeways.
They live near the subway.
They used to shouting over shit.
So she's out there.
This mother fucker trying to tell me what time it is,
baby.
Right.
And just screaming
and you know how much I curse.
Okay.
I was offended and you know how much I curse.
I was just like,
Jesus Christ,
can you please,
I might have kids someday.
Can you please stop cursing like that?
But I didn't say shit cause I,
I mean at that point I knew what was going to happen.
I would have been like,
oh it just would've been like,
excuse me,
could you do me a favor?
Could you use now don't you?
Nobody talking to you baby.
Right.
I didn't want to go through that whole fucking thing at her screaming at me.
Plus she was so fucking big,
she probably could've just choke,
slammed me and we would have had to have a new fucking table,
my room,
third fucking table that week.
And I'm a conservationalist is that the right word?
So,
oh my God,
fuck it.
Whatever.
So I don't say ship.
So then I go out to go do my show and of course I'm using my stupid smart phone.
I get lost,
I'm driving to upper Darby.
And it's just like,
well you know a fucking the white guy driving through there looking down at his
phone.
Yeah.
Cause you had to see where I am,
you know,
I did everything but roll down the window,
excuse me,
hustlers,
could you just stop hustling for a second?
I can just wondering if you could directly and the direction of this theater
that I'm performing in tonight.
You know,
horrific.
So,
uh,
I was so fucking mad.
I really got to get my temper together.
I could feel myself when my screen,
every time I had to go to make a turn,
I'm looking down at my map and the fucking phone would go black,
you know,
to save the battery.
And it was always what I needed to make a decision.
Then I would miss a turn and it got to the point I was squeezing my phone and I
knew what I was,
I was going to take it and I was just going to smash it down on the,
uh,
whatever you call that,
the,
the fucking thing that you'd not a gear shifter,
I guess it is geared to think you put it in gear.
It's not a stick shift.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
I was just going to smash the screen on that.
And I knew that,
that I,
I have my temporary control enough that I knew I couldn't do that shit.
So what I did was I just started screaming over and over again,
fuck you at my phone.
I was yelling,
fuck you at my in my car yelling fuck you would've phone blow.
That's why my voice is all scratchy right now.
Not because I,
I had,
I screamed for two shows is cause I was screaming at my cell phone.
So anyways,
I finally ended up getting there.
I ended up doing the show.
It's fucking phenomenal.
And whenever,
whenever I,
I
okay.
Do a show at a place like that.
MMM.
You know,
there's always some guy's been working the theater for like 2030 years and I
always walk up to the guy,
go,
you don't have to say any names,
just tell me some stories.
And this guy was telling stories about,
you know,
hanging out with motley Crue back during the hair metal days and going out to
strip clubs.
And he said he was there when guns and roses came through.
On the appetite for destruction tour.
He said afterwards,
he was standing in their tour bus and they're looking out their windshield and a
sea of groupies.
And at 1.1 member,
I'm not going to name names,
looked out and said,
what's up with those two?
And the guy said,
oh,
that,
that's actually,
believe it or not,
those aren't sisters.
That's a mother and a daughter.
And I guess they were really hot.
And the dude was like,
oh yeah,
bring him on the bus,
do it in my next life.
I want to be a fucking musician just to have the opportunity to have that level
of groupie.
Ah,
just fucking unreal.
So anyway,
so I dropped you off at Darby was just unbelievably depressing that people have
to live that way.
Fellow Americans have to live that way and that we're always sitting here
fucking acting like we give a shit about other countries and we need to help
out.
We don't.
All right,
well we,
I mean you give a shit or I give a shit,
but our government doesn't,
we're working our way in there to help them out.
Air quotes.
So we can take their natural resources.
All right.
That's how it is.
That's what the fuck is really going on.
If you ever wondered why,
all right,
they don't give a fuck about upper Darby,
new in New Orleans or whatever.
Fuck it.
All those blue collar towns that are failing out there in Ohio,
they don't give a shit about them cause they already own them.
So if there's any oil to be had,
they can just go in and suck it out of the ground
that it didn't make any fucking sense.
So anyway,
so I go back to my ghetto ass fucking Sheridan.
Okay.
All right.
I come walking in there and uh,
if this point,
it's one in the morning.
Now,
if it was one in the morning and I was at a nice hotel,
that'd be the usual thing.
There would be some people hanging down at the bar,
you know,
drinking,
getting ready to cheat on their spouses.
Dress nicely though.
All right?
But because it was a ghetto fucking Sheridan,
I went down there and most of the people in the lobby,
we're children running around screaming like one in the morning,
kids just running around.
I felt like I was in fucking Atlantic city.
You know those gamblers degenerate gamblers,
they don't fucking handle their kids.
Right,
right.
So just as see a fucking children.
I mean,
I was waiting for fucking,
you know,
Yoga was missing with somebody there,
gathering them like you could,
you could have had a children's choir.
That's how many fucking kids were there.
So I could go up the elevator and I,
and I get out,
get out of the elevator and I walked back up to my little,
you know,
I told you the front of the room look like a house and there was a door.
And then there's the window.
And as I'm looking at,
I'm at the doors,
I'm looking down to take out my hotel key.
I looked down and on the window sill is a three quarter eaten chicken.
Yeah.
Sitting on the fucking window sill.
I got pictures to prove it.
They're all going to be up on the m m m m podcast.com.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Is that the name of the website?
I know the name of the fucking website.
The Hell is wrong with me.
Yeah,
the MM.
The MM podcast.com.
Uh,
if you go up there,
I'll have all these pictures,
the pictures of,
uh,
the tower theater and all that.
I didn't take any pictures when I was driving to upper Darby could for obvious
fucking reasons.
I didn't want to be,
you know,
I just,
I would not want to be taking pictures down there cause people either think
you're a cop or you're just at a documentary.
They're level of poverty,
which would be fucking annoying to me if I was in that situation.
So anyways,
with that,
that was my,
Oh,
and then the next morning I woke up and uh,
I dropped my car off at budget.
It was fucking hilarious when he's hilarious.
Racial moments here is I go to get on the bus,
the bus drivers,
black five white guys get on it.
He asked us where we're going.
I go US air,
this guy says this,
so blah,
blah blah.
So we're driving in that and he's listening to this preacher because it's Sunday
morning and the guy,
you know,
he's talking about,
people need to be into Jesus and blah blah,
blah,
all this,
you know,
regular Jesus Shit.
Right.
But then all of a sudden he starts talking about Obama and,
and around him he's just starts kind of trashed and white people.
Yeah.
Just go,
oh we should be giving thanks to Jesus that has strong black man is president
and is not afraid to stand up to the white supremacy that we run in this
country.
And he's got it cranked.
Okay.
And I'm sitting there at fucking and all I did,
I'd just,
cause I wanted to have the laugh,
I just turned around and looked at all the other four white guys and then
everybody's just sort of sitting down looking at the wing tips like rarely,
what exactly is the call here?
Or can we say something?
You know,
excuse me,
we're not all white supremacists.
Yeah.
You know,
like what exactly is the proper response to that?
Because I thought it was,
I dunno.
I actually thought it was fucking hilarious.
I wish I could remember what the guy's saying.
Ah,
Jesus.
Now I'm fucking bomb.
And again on this fucking podcast.
All right,
let's,
let's get through the rest of the,
uh,
what am I going to do?
What am I going to do?
Some,
oh,
hey,
wait a minute.
Fucking NHL playoffs are coming up.
Everybody,
uh,
you excited?
Are you like me?
Do you like watching hockey Bruins?
Canadians?
Once again,
we're playing those fucking cunts up there with all their championships.
Do you know the more I read about the history of the NHL,
the less impressed with the Montreal Canadiens I am.
I mean I used to kind of give him shit cause I'm like,
dude,
you dominated a 16 league and they didn't even dominate the six team league.
It's like them and Toronto.
Montreal and Toronto basically had the same amount of cups right through the
early sixties.
I,
Montreal was ahead but not by much.
Um,
and then I found out later that the Canadian teams had been be,
no,
I couldn't give them shit because the Bruins where they are too.
So it's like,
well,
why didn't you guys do it?
And I found out one of the main fucking reasons is,
is the way the league was set up,
any French born Canadian player,
the Canadian teams had first dibs on those guys.
That's why they got all the fucking great guys.
So it's like Toronto and Montreal were just like the Yankees and red sox fucking
buying up everything.
I don't respect,
I don't respect those championships.
What do you think about that Montreal?
Um,
and that what happened all of a sudden you didn't have first fucking choice,
right?
And now look,
now you don't go on a run anymore.
You want it 93 one in 86 and that's it.
And don't even talk to me about the seventies.
Okay.
I don't want even fucking hear it because that was still the fallout of the old,
the old system.
You had to give those,
those expansion six teams a chance to get on their feet.
And once they did,
that was the NTU guys.
So I'm not fucking impressed.
So fuck you and all your fucking cops.
He had come the Bruins and you know what,
keep your fucking head up or we're going to slam you into that.
Turnbuckle whatever the fuck they call it again,
that son of a bitch up,
they're fake and his father good.
It can cause the worst concussion ever.
Three days later he's at the movies.
He's at the movies.
All right,
I'm just fucking with you.
Okay.
Uh,
broads Canadians going to be an awesome series and a carry prices playing great.
So it should be,
uh,
should be phenomenal.
I don't think the Bruins are going to win the Stanley Cup.
I just don't think we have enough guys.
And I just think that despite the fact that we have two great goaltenders,
I just think that there's a lot of goaltenders playing great.
Kerry prices playing great.
A Henrik Lundqvist is playing tremendous.
Uh,
who else?
Who else is playing good out there?
Oh,
he got,
he got what's his face up there and buy?
Can't ever remember the fucking name.
Who plays,
who plays goalie up there in Buffalo.
Bill Murray.
Is that,
what is that word called?
Bill Murray.
And then you got fucking Roberta Lou Longo and his cousin,
a Theo flurries third cousin who plays out there and fucking Pittsburgh.
I'm the worst.
I can,
when I went up,
I have to remember a name.
I can't remember her fucking name.
So whatever.
I think it's good.
I think it's going to be a
think.
It's going to be great.
I just don't see it.
I think I will be really happy if we can actually make it to the eastern
conference finals.
You know,
that's my thing.
You know what?
Hey,
I'm,
I'm beaten down as a fan,
as long as we don't go up three games to none and then lose four in a row.
Again,
I'm going to consider this year of victory,
but I do not on any level want to lose to the hated fucking habs.
Um,
and I'm fucking with you a bunch of cups,
but not really.
Okay.
Let's get onto advice this week,
everybody.
All right.
Hey Bill,
I always feel like you give great advice.
Well,
thank you.
So I thought maybe you could give me some in this situation.
I was in a local shop a few weeks ago and there was a little hottie work in
there.
Um,
I had seen her there once before and both times she really caught my attention.
I had the urge to ask her out while I was there,
but I was too busy be enough.
And I did.
And I did not say anything to her other than some idle nonsense about
sunglasses.
I was looking at,
oh,
that's the worst.
Uh,
the little bit we did talk though,
she seemed really cool and really nice.
My advice is how can slash should I ask her out without looking like,
mmm.
Coming off like a creeper,
a douchebag.
I'm a good looking guy,
have a great career as an attorney.
But when it comes to ladies,
I can be shy.
Sometimes saying is that,
you know,
that's a very strong thing that you're able to admit that.
But every guy just went,
ah,
I was mad at you fucking fag.
Go up and say something to her.
That's,
that's how guys handle.
We just beat it out of each other.
Okay.
We said,
watch I'm trying to work on,
he says every once in a while you see a girl that blows you away.
And uh,
this time I wanted to do something
about it.
Uh,
all right.
All right dude,
this is what you gotta do.
You got,
you gotta get you gotta work on your self esteem.
Okay?
You know,
you're a good looking guy and you have a great career.
Believe it or not,
that's game set and match.
Do you know the amount of fucking not even good looking guys who have a shit job
and they're just scumbags,
but they're assholes who are out there fucking crushing it every God damn
weekend cause he just had the balls to walk up and talk to these women.
You know,
this is what you gotta do.
You actually know what you gotta do.
You said you can be shy sometimes,
but you're saying you're working on it.
So there you go.
Just keep waiting.
It looked out.
She probably light if you're a good looking guy.
And you're a fucking attorney.
He actually said something here.
I'm hoping to see you.
What Caroline's in May if I,
my Dick had friends can get this shit together if they can't.
Maybe with your stellar advice,
I can even bring this hottie to the show.
Why don't you just do that?
Go in there and make her laugh.
Joke around what there are in anything and just,
just fucking lay it on the line.
Listen,
I'm really attracted to you.
I think you beautiful.
Ever the fuck you want to say it.
It just say,
you know,
I think it's always good if you have somewhere that you're going,
just say,
I'm going to this comedy show I love,
you know,
I'm really into this standup comedian.
I have an exit ticket,
which you like to go to women like going to stuff,
you know,
gives him an excuse to get dressed up.
It gives him an excuse to not feel fucking guilty when they're blowing you later
cause they actually went to some sort of ball or some shit,
you know?
Ah,
God,
yeah.
Even with the advice I'm off of this week,
but the essence of it is there.
All right.
You already talked to her.
Just go in there again.
You're not going to come off like a creep.
I actually think that it's easier to pick somebody up and get that number.
At least back in the day.
I have no game left anymore cause I've been in a relationship too long,
but I always found that it was easier for me to get a girl's phone number on
the,
at the fucking Jim.
Jim's a little bit harder but like I should do it on ice to get it on the
subway.
Oddly enough,
I had a better chance there than I did in some meat market bar because I,
I was never good when females had their guards up when they knew what play I was
running.
Some guys can do that.
They like the old packers.
Like everybody knew the packer sweep was coming and they,
Forrest Gregg still fucking ran over you and some guys are like that.
Even when women know they got to dare fucking guard up and they know what the
fuck they're doing.
They could still plow through it.
They run over,
the guys just run right over those girls like Forrest Gregg and next thing you
know,
they're laying on their backs with their legs up in the air and they get the
Dick.
I was never that guy.
Okay.
I was,
I snuck up on you.
I waited for something stupid to happen that I could comment on.
And then I get the girl laughing.
And then when her fuck her defenses were down,
I a I'd wrestle her cell phone up from her fingers.
No,
I would have,
I'd somehow get her number.
So what I would do was I would just go in there and,
uh,
I'll just keep reexplaining this 20 fucking times,
do get tickets to my show,
right?
Look at me.
I'll make a little money out of this advice.
So now you've got,
you've got somewhere that you got to take her.
Take Your Rod,
you know,
little dinner,
the ski comedy show.
She's already fucking laughing halfway through my AGI.
You do the old,
you're laughing your ass off.
Don't try to put your arm around the shoulder.
That's old school right.
You put it right on a fucking die,
you know,
and then you sorta start creeping up there with your fingers.
You know like you sorta thinking about something going Pinky,
ring,
Middle Index.
He just sort of work your way up like an inch worm.
And next thing you know if your,
if your,
if your fingers are Nimble enough,
you know you stretch out your picky,
it's gotta Rub it right on a click there
and then you get made fun of me cause you guys are fucking walking out during my
clothes and fit to go bang at the fucking w around the corner.
It,
it's right there.
It's a lay up to fucking lay up.
All right,
next one.
Hey Bill,
huge fan of the podcast and all your stand up and have made all my friends big
fans of yours as well.
I really enjoyed the relationship advice,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
All right.
People ask me is starting to address the fact that I've never been married.
Why am I taking your fucking advice?
Uh,
here's my situation.
I'm 29,
recently graduated from medical school after a good number of years.
Uh,
honing my boning skills in the free market.
I'm ready to calm down and have a serious girlfriend.
Ironically.
Um,
the girl that I'm dating and wanting to get serious with was actually my college
girlfriend and first love.
We dated throughout college for broke up before attending different medical
schools during our years together.
I cheated a lot,
but to my knowledge never got caught.
A big part of the reason that I was so promiscuous besides being your typical
piece of shit,
cocky asshole guy full of test testosterone was because she was very sexually
inhibited,
no blow jobs,
the routine conventional positions sex about once every other day.
And that just wasn't cutting it for me.
Now,
in every other case,
now in every other category,
she was amazing fun to hang out with,
but still lady like carrying respectable,
educated,
fashionable and extremely beautiful.
So like I said before,
we broke up for about five years and our back dating again and the sex is
exactly the same now.
While I'm grateful that some guy didn't completely smother out during our
breakup.
I did expect it did expect some sort of sexual maturation.
Um,
okay.
Blowjobs remained few and far between and pretty sub par even for a black chick
disguise black by the way,
before you think this is something fucked up.
Um,
what makes it even more difficult this time around is after banging my fair
share of broad in our off season,
uh,
my sexual prowess has grown significantly.
It's hard because I really want to be faithful this time around and take the
relationship more seriously,
but a fear I'm not going to be sexually satisfied.
My greatest fear is ending up like one of my father's friends who I always hear
complaining about how shitty their sex lives have become after marriage.
Um,
how I should have had all my fun now and Blah,
blah,
stereotypical castrated,
merry men,
background noise.
Uh,
fuck that extra sad shit.
I'm not getting married unless I know my wife is going to be a lady in the
streets in a freak in the sheets.
How do you like that old African American mantra?
Uh,
my question is how serious should I take this problem?
Should I be patient and hope that I can liberate her sexually or should I bail
and keep searching for a god-fearing dinner?
Cooking super freak if you don't mind asking.
Uh,
Oh,
if you don't mind asking Nia as well,
I'd like to hear what the sister has to say.
Oh,
Shit.
I should have read that to her by the way.
I'm also black.
So when you get to,
is it racist,
racist,
racist?
No,
I'm allowed to say sisters.
Uh,
all right.
Um,
you know what?
I really wish I read that part of what it had around here,
but she's not around today.
Um,
what should you do?
All right.
Number one,
don't cheat on her.
Uh,
what you should do is you should,
you should communicate this tour.
Uh,
obviously not the way he just said it to me.
Um,
well,
Jesus,
this is,
this is tough.
I,
I'd have to ask you some questions.
Let me ask you this.
Do you feel she has the potential?
That's what that would be.
My number one thing
is,
all right,
this is how I would do it.
Right?
Fuck this.
All right.
Now,
now back on track.
This is what I would do.
First thing I would do is I would,
I would see if she has the potential.
All right.
If she's a good kisser,
if she has a good touch,
if when you're banging her,
you don't feel like you're fucking riding in a god did the back of a delivery
truck.
Okay.
The rhythms there,
if she has is she has the basic tools.
All right?
Because some people,
they just don't,
they,
they're not blessed with the touch then that good kissers you know,
and a lot of females,
not a lot,
but you know enough are,
that's another thing they never bring up.
They always talk about how guys don't know shit and bed and you just blah,
blah,
blah.
But there's a lot of women out there who they don't know shit either.
Not saying they're bad or whatever,
but in some of them just,
I just never going to be good.
So if you feel she has the potential then,
then there's hope.
So what you have to do is you have to basically what I used to tell my friends,
we used to joke around,
just say you got to tap into her inner whore.
All right?
And the visit a couple of ways to do it.
One of them.
And it's very delicate dude.
It's like one of those fucking action movies where you'd sit in there trying to
clip the right fucking wire as it's,
you know,
eight seconds left.
Um,
there's a couple of ways you go about it.
Okay.
Uh,
one of the ways is,
well first of all,
this does a couple of rules.
One,
as she's trying to open up with you sexually or whatever,
don't ever judge anything that she wants to,
to uh,
try and don't ever make fun of anything that she said it bed.
If she says some dumb shit,
which she's probably gonna say,
cause you sound like you're way more experienced if she's trying to talk dirty
for the first fucking time and she says some dumb shit,
do not laugh.
Simply turn her around and doggy style and then you get your laugh out.
All right,
you got to do the quad,
but don't ever do that.
That is like someone is never more vulnerable than in that specialty of female.
You can't,
you can't do that.
And then what she,
I would,
I would do is I would just basically figure out what she's into trying to figure
out what some of her fantasies are.
All right.
So that,
that's how I would start it.
Find out what some of her fantasies are and you start getting her down that
road.
And then as you're going down that road and you're not judging her and you're
not making fun of any,
you just supportive as she goes down that fucking road.
Um,
then she'll gain confidence and then Dan,
hopefully that'll happen.
And one of the ways to kind of lead her down the road is try to tell us some of
the shit that you're into that you've never done with her.
Then I'll go all the way down to the road.
You know,
your five years of fucking horrific shit.
You did just always be a couple of paces out in front of whatever sexual shit
that she admitted that she wanted to do.
So that way her shit doesn't seem as freaky because it's a couple of steps
behind you,
but you don't completely freak her the fuck out by,
you know,
talking about some German porn shit.
All right,
so that,
that's what,
uh,
that's what I would do.
All right.
And that's what I have been doing throughout the years.
Nia,
look who just walked in.
Somebody actually asked your advice
because you were working out.
Do you want to do this?
Okay.
All right.
You know,
what do I have?
I don't have my other microphone,
so we actually have to be over here and let me ask you this shit real quickly.
I'll give you the basic overview.
All right.
There was a guy,
right?
He sees this girl,
they like each other.
The heist did the college sweethearts.
Everything about her,
um,
was,
was great.
They have fun too.
She's knee is a little under the weather here.
All right.
Are fucking allergies are kicking up.
Let me hear your voice.
Say Hello.
Hello
and you worked out what a fucking trooper.
All right.
Real quick.
Yeah,
so everything hanging out,
they'd laughed each at each other's jokes.
The whole shit was perfect.
But then they went to different medical schools.
All right.
So they broke up for a while.
And during the,
you know,
the five years,
I guess this guy cheated a lot when he was with her and now five years have gone
by,
he got his free cow.
Uh,
if you saw the look of disgust on her face,
he did all this shit.
So now he's back together with her.
All right.
And he was kind of hoping like as a sex was kind of lame,
like when he was with her missionary position,
very like if you like,
if you're going to make like a,
like a high school video on how to have sex,
the mail takes out his penis.
What aroused?
Like they were having that kind of sex and no blow jobs whatsoever.
So now he's gotten back together with her.
He wants to be serious.
He's gotten all this,
hopefully all this bullshit out and now he's back with their,
and the sex is basically the same.
Now there's a couple of blow jobs.
So he's wondering how does he get her to tap into her inner whore?
Should he pursue that he pursue this relationship?
Like how,
okay.
How does a guy do that?
Like how,
like I said,
basically how I do it.
Oh,
she's already just saying,
give me the mic.
All right,
go ahead.
Uh,
well,
first of all,
just because you enjoy sex in different ways,
does it make you a horse so she doesn't have to tap into our inner whore?
Just more freedom.
It's actually,
has he tried to talk?
You don't need to clarify it.
Okay.
I'm not saying she's a whore.
We understand this.
Okay.
I felt the need to clarify
to put your fist in the air for women right now.
Okay.
Uh,
did he try to talk to her about this before and she just ignored it?
I don't think he's talked to her about it yet.
So it's,
you know,
it's,
it's the first step is that he's got to talk to her.
That's what I said.
Look at that.
Why don't we switch it up a little bit and I wonder why she didn't give him blow
jobs.
Maybe she just doesn't like giving gloves out.
Maybe she doesn't know how,
but it could be fun to explore together.
So he should,
yeah,
you should ask her about it.
Just saying,
okay,
this especially what I said.
Yeah.
You know what's the worst is when women say they can't do it cause they have TMJ
and it's like what?
They don't like to do it.
Some people don't like to do it,
you know,
it's not,
it's not that great for the other person,
but it's like some people don't like it.
Some guys don't like to go down on girls.
Some girls don't like to go down and dies.
It's just a preference thing.
Okay.
All right.
So you basically said what?
I said,
I thought you wouldn't come in here with some soda.
Yeah.
Does that make you feel bad?
No,
but I just,
yeah,
I thought I would be coming at it in a different,
more rational,
sensitive way.
But she said the same thing,
Huh?
Yeah,
but not as sensitively.
I said all the Horse Shit.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah,
that's,
I don't know what I thought that it was going to continue.
I don't mean it like that.
I just said in a mean way.
Can we come over here and get a hug?
Give a hug.
Um,
I'm coming towards the end of the,
uh,
the podcast.
All right.
There you go.
When I get Outta here,
cause you've been,
you've been,
you've been more than helpful.
All right.
She just gave me the finger.
Now you know what it is yet,
whenever you're on the podcast and then the podcast segment ends.
I don't know how to smoothly transition you out of here because we don't go to
commercial.
Why don't I just go ladies and gentleman?
Nay.
Nia,
everybody.
Thanks so much.
Thank you so much Neal.
See you next time.
You were great.
And now what the fuck just happened to Mike?
I hate computers.
It just signed me off and I was on a nice little fucking roll here
and now I can't.
I can't get back into my,
my,
my fucking,
yeah.
How is this easier?
People I want,
I want people to,
now I have to go into my fucking,
my stupid apple works.
All right.
Here I am.
Fucking,
all right.
I'm going to read one more of these and that's going to be the podcast for this
week.
All right.
Uh,
hey bill,
I need an outside perspective.
My wife left me a year and a half ago to go blow college guys and spend her
newly raise salary on clothes and purses.
Yeah,
not kidding.
That's what she did.
After nine years and two kids,
I found out that she had two short affairs after each kid was born.
Then left me with our five month old baby and two year old I had been raising
without her.
Anyways,
Jesus,
Oh gee,
I'm a year later,
she finally started trying to share custody.
She didn't have her hit her half of daycare.
I'm sorry.
People every once in a while I go back to my bad reading habits.
Let me just take a breath here.
Step back,
focus.
All right.
A year later,
she finally started trying to custody.
Okay.
So after she's gone up,
she left him with two kids to go blow college guys and spend all her money.
She just got on our newly higher salary.
I'm a year later,
she finally started trying to share custody.
She didn't have her half of daycare,
um,
bill for a few months,
even though she doubles my income.
So I told her she could pay me back.
Now the current gets her tax return and tells me to fuck off.
She's not repaying me.
She's going to get a car to replace the one she totaled in a Dui.
Jesus,
where did you meet this winter?
I'm pissed off and can't blast her in the jaw.
So what do I do?
I'm thinking of hiring a crack head to spray paint dead beat on her fucking car
for one asshole to another.
Thanks bill.
The podcast and all three cds of helped me through a lot of tough shit by
laughing off the retarded shit that this cut does.
MMM.
All right,
dude.
Uh,
yeah.
You,
you picked a winner here.
This is like,
this is one of these ones that you should ask Dr drew about.
Um,
who's amazing and he would hit his half court shot and tell you exactly what's
going on.
This,
there's something going on with her where she has affairs right after she has
kids.
I don't know what that is,
but that's triggering something inside of her.
Um,
I don't know if she gets freaked out with the level of responsibility and she
wants to,
I dunno,
do a bunch get it go.
So her oats and a female fucking way failing.
Like I dunno,
you know,
some,
sometimes women have babies and then they had that postpartum depression.
She has some sort of postpartum like you know,
hedonism that she just goes out and just turns into the fuck fest 2011.
So what you have there,
do you have damaged goods?
There's no way you can ever fucking trust her again.
You got two kids.
So,
um,
don't do anything to her.
All right.
This is like in sports where when somebody comes up and slashes,
Yah.
Yeah,
the ref never sees it.
But when you retaliate,
you always end up getting the fucking five minute major.
This is what's going to happen.
She's going to do all this dumb shit.
You're going to hire people to do stuff or I know you're not going to literally
do that,
but you can try to exact some sort of revenge and I dunno if the decent person
always seems to get caught.
So I would avoid doing that.
Okay,
this is how you get your event is
I would just focus on being a great dad for those two kids.
In all honesty,
I know that's a ton of work and it's easy for me to say when I don't have any
kids and I never ever bad mouth their mother.
Okay
to them.
Never do that.
You know,
have a buddy of yours where you can just vent and just talk about what a cunt
she is as you're punching the bar but never do it in front of your kids cause
that's still their mother.
Eventually they'll figure out what an irresponsible whore she is.
And this is going to be,
that's going to be your great payback is in that moment,
not only are they going to realize what an irresponsible horror their mother is,
is they're going to realize what a great dad they have and a,
which is obviously going to be priceless.
Um,
and in the meantime,
I would ask myself is if this,
this,
this lady,
if this is the kind of per dev you met a girl like this a number of times,
is it's just bad luck or do like every woman,
every woman that you've dated is like this.
Because if that is the case,
there's something about these kinds of women that you're attracted to.
And,
and as I've always used that analogy,
you keep fishing in the same poisoned pond.
Uh,
I think because you got two kids and you want to go out and go meet a winter,
I go out to that debt shit,
where are you going to meet a decent girl?
Go out,
go take a cooking class.
I just gave on Nia for birthday.
A fucking almost said Goddamn year ago.
She finally got around to it,
a couple of gourmet cooking classes and she went there and it's kind of like a
little scene,
you know,
people bring wine in your cooking.
There's all that fucking people,
a taste and shit.
All the senses are going that pussies getting wet in the room.
You go in there,
you fucking knock a couple out or whatever.
Join a softball league.
I don't know what all those,
a lot of boozing was softball,
you know,
probably going to get some bloated whore there.
You might want to stay away from that.
Maybe that's where you go to vent about what a fucking whore you're wife is.
But Dude,
you know what?
You're a great fucking guy.
You're doing the right thing.
You sticking with your kids and your even supporting her,
even though she's making more fucking money.
She's a loser.
All right?
She's a fucking loser and she's out of your life and your kids will be 18 one
day and then this bitch will be out of your life.
So who gives a fuck?
All right.
In the meantime.
Yeah,
focus on being a good dad.
Get yourself in great shape.
I don't know.
Find some fucking way to do something social.
Go meet a great woman.
I can't say there's plenty of great women out there.
It's just like guys,
they're out there.
Go find one and just ask them during the day,
just be like,
by the way,
are you a,
are you an irresponsible whore?
Because I,
I really just got out of relationship with an irresponsible whore and I'm not
trying to try and do that and talk about cheating.
Ask if they ever cheated on somebody is another great question to ask.
Ask if their parents are still together.
That's a great one to ask.
The parents are still together.
If they get along with their parents,
they come from a strong background.
That's a good one to ask a man.
That's a good place to start off and that's it.
I'm done trying to be doctor bill here for the week.
Um,
our and six minute podcasts.
Once again,
I'm going to be done.
The
Catalina jazz club,
um,
doing a benefit for all those people out there in Japan,
fellow human beings who also live on a fault line just like I do.
Um,
so,
uh,
hopefully somebody out there,
we'll do a fucking comedy show for when La falls into the ocean,
so I'm paying it forward.
All right,
so come on down.
All the proceeds will go out to help the victims of that.
This Catalina Jazz club down on Sunset Boulevard,
um,
I just tweeted about it,
uh,
at [inaudible] dot com I think that's it.
Uh,
we got all the youtube videos.
It didn't get a chance to describe youtube videos this week,
but they're fucking hilarious.
Uh,
some guy has a potato gun that he shoots a bunch of pubes onto a passed out guy.
That's one of them and it just goes from there.
It just goes from there.
So I'll go to the FM podcast to watch all that.
If you want to see the pictures of the tower theater and me working with Joe to
Rosa,
the teen idol sensation from the opiate Anthony Program.
I have all of those and I have a picture of that fucking chicken wings sitting
on my window sill.
Just in case you'd think I was making it up.
Fucka uh,
that's it.
Everybody have a great week.
Go Fuck yourself and I'll talk to you next week.
Oh wait,
I don't hang up.
Don't hang up.
I almost forgot.
I almost forgot I told you that I was going to bring in the,
uh,
the outtake from a,
my failed attempt at the podcast last week.
This is like a special track.
Remember that back in the day when you'd buy like a CD and they'd say they'd be
like 15 songs,
but it would say 16 tracks and they would just let the tape run and run and run
and run.
And then you'd,
you'd find the A,
that little gem at the end.
I think this is,
this is the podcast version cause I already signed off.
Um,
all right,
just to set this up,
this was me last night after getting like four hours sleep flying across this
country and then watching the math and I'm trying to tell that Sheridan story.
And up until this point,
it just had not been funny.
And I think I met the part of the story with a guy,
uh,
was bringing the new table to,
to replace the broken table in.
And a,
I was trying to explain it in a funny way.
It wasn't funny and I just,
I just fucking tapped out.
Uh,
and this is the clip.
Hope you enjoy it.
I'll talk to you next week.
And I was like,
Jesus Christ.
Then I heard an argument
between a man and a woman as I was walking back downstairs,
and later on that night when I came back from my Gig,
there was a fucking half eaten chicken wing sitting on the window sill.
My Room.
I got a picture of it.
You know,
I actually,
you know something,
when I knew,
I knew something was up,
when I went to check into my room,
ah,
there was a knock at my door five seconds later and the guy goes,
oh,
hey.
And he's got this big table.
I'm like,
dude,
you got the wrong room.
I didn't order a table.
He said,
no,
no.
I said,
this,
this table belongs in your room.
He goes,
somebody broke it here last night,
and I was like,
Jesus,
what was their party here at something?
He was like,
yeah,
I go,
well,
did you fumigate the place or is it just all judges and coke residue when here?
And he just laughed,
shook his head and left and that's when my ass knew was in a ghetto
ass mother.
Fucking Sheridan baby is part.